hey this is presh talwalkar
how many holes does a straw have
this question has created a lot of
debate online
buzzfeed recently created a video that
already has over 450 000 views
this is amazing it's a topology topic
that's going viral
topology is a branch of mathematics
dealing with the study of shapes and it
was important for the 2016 nobel prize
in physics
now i've noticed something interesting
when a matter of science gets in the
news you always have scientists that are
consulted
when a matter of law gets in the news
you always have lawyers that are quoted
you always have experts that are quoted
when those topics get in the news
what happens when mathematics gets in
the news
well people just debate it
so i am begging buzzfeed and the media
please please reach out to math people
like me and other math people who are on
social media for such topics it's a
great time where we can educate people
about mathematics for something they're
already discussing
so
how many holes does a straw have
what was the debate centered around here
are a few of the popular answers
many people thought a straw has two
holes
there's one hole at the top and there's
one hole at the bottom
there's another camp of people that says
a straw just has one hole it's a really
long hole
now there are also some people who said
a straw has zero holes
if you puncture one side of a straw with
the needle
you would say the straw has one hole
so an undamaged straw starts with zero
holes
so these are a few of the answers that
people gave to this question
but which one is correct mathematically
give this a try and when you're ready
keep watching the video and i'll give
the mathematical explanation to this
question
so how many holes does a straw have
here's a short mathematical proof for
why it has one hole
a straw is topologically equivalent to
the product of s1
and the interval 0l where s1 is a unit
circle and l is the length of the straw
since s1 has one hole
and the interval 0l has no holes a straw
has one hole
this is essentially the argument that i
read in the article drinking straws how
many holes by kevin knudsen who's a
professor of mathematics at the
university of florida and a forbes
contributor
so what exactly does this mathematical
proof mean
intuitively
well
let me explain this in a little animated
fashion
so we'll start with the circle s1
now we would agree this has one hole
inside
the inside of the circle is a hole it's
a two-dimensional space that's contained
by a one-dimensional simple closed
now what we're going to do is we're
going to give the circle depth this will
be the product s1 with the interval 0l
so there you see it there's one hole
you have the length of the straw and the
other side is still the same hole
so the straw has exactly one hole
even if we scale it down to the shape
that we're familiar with so that's the
answer the straw has one hole
topologically
is that what you thought
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math
you can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions if you like this video please
check out my books which are listed in
the video description and you can
support me on patreon
if you have a mathematical topic or
puzzle you can email me presh
mindyourdecisions.com and you can catch
me on social media either at mind your
decisions or at preshtalwalkar